[موسيقى]
اذا الغيم تنهمر الحروف
فان لبست مقاليد المعاني مسطره
تنوء بها الرفوف
فتحنا في صميم العلم بابا فقال الدهر قد
جاز الوقوف
[موسيقى]
الشعر ليس حمامات نطيرها نحو السماء ولا
ناين ريح صدى لكنه غضب طالت اظافره ما
اجمل الشعر ان لم يركب الغضب السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
يقول الله تعالى في سوره الواقعه
وبست الجبال وبسه فكانت هباء منبثها فما
المقصود بقوله جثه الجبال بسه
البسيسه عند العرب الدقيق المطحون طحنا
شديدا تلت بسمن او زيت ونحو ذلك
قال بعض المفسرين جثه الجبال بسى اي فتته
الجبال فصارت كالدقيق المبسوس وهو المبلول
قال الراجس لا تخبز خبزا وبسا بسا ولا
تطيل بمناخ حبسه
في سوره المزمل يقول تعالى
وكانت الجبال كثيبا مهيلا
الكثيب هو الرمل الدقيق الناعم والمهيل هو
السائل قال بعض المفسرين وكانت الجبال
رملا سائلا متناثرا وللعربي في ذلك لغتان
تقول العرب مهيل ومهيول ومكيل ومكيول
وفي سوره طه يقول سبحانه وتعالى
ويسالونك عن الجبال فقل ينسفها ربي نسفا
في ذره فيضرها قاعا صفصفا
ينسفها من النسف يقال نسفت الريح التراب
نسفه اذا اقتلعته وفرقته
اتفقت المعاني واختلفت الانفاق في هذه
الايات الثلاثه
هنا وقفه اريد ان اقفها مع كلمه الجبال
كثير من الجيل الناشئ لا ينطقون اللام في
كلمه الجبال كلام قمريه ويقولون الجبال
هذه وهذا اللفظ لفظ خطا تماما المفروض ان
توضح وتخرج اللام من مخرجها الصحي وتقول
الجبال ولا تقل الجبال هذا اولا ثانيا
يعني كما ترون هذه الايات كلها مرتبطه
بيوم القيامه حين همم تنسوا الجبال فلا
نقول الا ما قاله الاولون اللهم قنا عذابك
يوم تبعث عبادك
مريضه ابو الطيب المتنبي وهو في مصر وكان
له صديق مخلص يعوده كل يوم في علته فلما
قبل اي تعافى انقطع الصديق عنه فكتب ابو
الطيب اليه وصلتني وصلك الله معتله
وقطعتني مبل فان رايت ان لا تحبب العله
الي ولا تكبر الصحه عليك فعلت ان شاء الله
وهذا من الكتب الذكيه جدا التي فيها معنا
جميل ولفظ موجز واصيل
[موسيقى]
الفزلكه هي جمال الكلام بعد تفصيله يقال
انه اصلها فذلك كذا وكذا
ايجاز الكلام الطويل
فنقول مثلا كان لدي حصانه ثم جاء باربعه
احصنه اخرى فذلك سته احصنه هذه هي
اليوم للاسف اخذت الفذلك بعدا اخر صارت
الناس تقول كلمه الفذلك عن الاطاله
والاطناب في الاحاديث التي ليس من ورائها
فائده هل نستطيع ان نفذلك بغير كلمه فذلك
نعم تستطيع ان نقول هذه تفاحه وهاتان
تفاحهتان فتلك ثلاث تفاحه فنحن فذلكنا
باستخدام كلمه تلك وهذا معنى ورد في كتاب
الله تعالى في
يقول الله تعالى اا فمن لم يجد فصيام
ثلاثه ايام في الحج وسبعه اذا رجعتم تلك
10 كامله وهذا نوع من انواع الفذلك في
القران الكريم
اا الشامه اثر اسود في البدن وفي الارض
الناس تسمي بناتها شيماء
و بعضهن يسمين شيماء بدون همزه ورد في
لسان العرب الشامه علامه مخالفه لسائر
اللون والجمع شامات وشام
في ابيات تنسب لي ياقوت الحموي يقول فيها
له
خال على صفحات خد كنقطه عنبر في صحن مرمر
واجفان باسياف تنادي على عاصي الهوى الله
اكبر
قال المعتمد بن عباد في ابيات من فرائد
الابيات
حرم النوم علينا ورقد وابتلانا بهواه ثم
صد يا هلال حسن خدا يا رشا
وانجي لحضن يا قضيبا لين قد
وقال بشار بن برد وطال علي الليل حتى كانه
بليلين موصول فما تزحزح كان الدجاجه زادت
وما زادت الدجى ولكن اطال الليل هم مبرحو
وقال للعباس بن الاحنف ابكي الذين اذا
قومي مودتهم حتى اذا ايقظوني للهوى ردوا
لاخرجن من الدنيا وحبهم بين الجوارح لم
يشعر به احد
وقال محدثكم ابكي الذين اذااقوني مودتهم
كالصبر طعما وكل فقدان حرمانه
كالدمع كالليل كالدنيا اذا انتهزت كلب
باسم متخذا في الناس الوان
[موسيقى]
اذا كنت تقصد ان تقول عن شيء انه يشبه
البيضه فقل انه بيضوي الشكل لا بيضاوي
بالنسبه الى البيضه هي البيضاوي كالارض
البيضاويه مثلا اما البيضاويه فهي نسبه
مؤنثه الى اللون ومعناه بيضاء كقولك هذه
سحب بيضاويه
يستخدم كلمه نكهه بمعنى الطعام وهذا
استخدام خطا ففي لسان العرب نكحه اي شم
رائحه فمه والاسم النكهه وفي القاموس نكهه
له ونكهه عليه اي تنفس على انفه او اخرج
نفسه الى انف اخر اذا الافضل ان تقولوا
عصير بمذاق كذا لا بنكهتك كذا
[موسيقى]
ورش للدلاله على المشاغب الذي لا يهدا ولا
يستقيم في جلسه والكلمه من اصل فصيح جاء
في لسان العرب الوارش النشيط اما في
القاموس فهي الخفيف من الابل وغيرها
[موسيقى]
بين يدي ايها الاعزاء كتاب الاعمال
الشعريه للشاعر البطاقه شهاده الطاقه رجل
عراقي ولد في عام
1929 من القرن الماضي وكان رجلا دبلوماسيا
واديبا ومن شعراء المدرسه الحداثيه الذين
اسسوا بدايه ظهور شعر التفعيله مع بدر
شاكر السياب ونازك الملائكه وعبد الوهاب
البياتي طبعا هذا الكتاب له قصه جميله هو
انه
وصلني هديه من صديقي
في جامعه السوربون ولذلك تجده كتب لي
الاهداء بالعربي والفرنسي يقول لصديقي
العزيز محمد بون لكتور يعني قراءه جيده او
قراءه ممتعه شاذل نواف طاقه بتاريخ
15/02/2020 هذه المعلومه لا تهمك عزيزي
المشاهد ولكن ما يهمك
هو انه عندما اهداني هذا الكتاب قص عليه
قصه جميله قال طبعا جده شاهد طاقه كان
وكيلا لوزاره الثقافه وكان وكيلا لوزاره
الخارجيه وبعد ذلك تبوا منصب وزير
الخارجيه في العراق همم في ايام الرئيس
احمد حسن البكر وكان قبلها سفيرا للعراق
في الاتحاد السوفيتي القصه هي ان الشاعر
الكبير نزار قباني كان صديقا لهذا الرجل
وعندما ذهب نزار قباني الى منزل السيد
بلقيس الراوي من اجل ان يخطبها الى ابيها
همم رفض ابوها
فتوصف لهذه الخطبه الرئيس العراقي الاسبق
احمد حسن البكر وارسل
ما نسميه جاهتا من اجل ان يخطبوها فكان من
بين الذين ارسلهم الرئيس وزير الخارجيه
شهاده الطاقه ومعه ايضا اخرون منهم الاديب
شفيق الكمالي والاديب علي كمال وبعد ذلك
وافق طبعا ابوها وتزوجت بلقيس من نزار
فهذه هي القصه المرتبطه في ذهني بتاريخ
الاهداء وبهذا الكتاب فانا اشكر صديقي
نواف طاقه ايضا على هذه الاهداءات اهداوني
كتب اخرى طبعا
لافراد من العائله لكن اريد ان اقرا عليكم
شيئا من شعر الرجل طبعا هذا الكتاب
فيه من الاشعار التقليديه وفيه من شعر
التفعيله هنا قصيده من بيت واحد بعنوان
خيبه يقول ولقد مررت على الديار فلم اجد
غير الهوى متنقرا بثيابي
واما قصيدته المعنونه عروس بغداد فيقول
فيها
تارج فيك النسيم الندي او مرضت الفرقد
ردي علي طيوف الكرى وجودي بطيبك للمجهد
وذوبي على شفتي نغمه يقصر عنها غنى معبدي
وحومي على المقلتين من الحب محمومه
المشادي
شعر جميل
فيه الكثير همم
السهل الممتنع هنا قصيده مكتوب انها القيت
في مهرجان الشارع الثامن الذي عقد في
القاهره في عام
1968 يقول هدرت وقد وجع الهواء بها عن
قاؤه لا تكبوا ولا تكذبوا مشوفه بالريح
تعرفها والريح تنقى وهي تقترب
من من عجب ال ال ال المواقف ان الحارس اخو
شادل طاقه قضى نحبه في نفس الانفجار الذي
استهدف السفاره العراقيه في بيروت والذي
توفيت فيه بلقيس زوجه نزار قباني عليهم
رحمه الله جميعا اذا الاعمال الشعريه لهذا
الطاقه كتاب لهذا اليوم
[موسيقى]
سالتكم في تويتر ما اصدق شاعر قالته العرب
في
دواوينها وقصائدها وفيما يستعرض معكم بعض
ما وصلني من مشاركاتكم
احمد الخزاعي يقول وما من يد الا يد الله
فوقها ولا ظالم الا سيبلى باظلم
هذا احمد الخزاعي واما شامي فقال لا يوجد
اصدق من بيت ابن زهير كل ابن انثى وان
طالت سلامته يوما على اله حدباء محمول
مشاركه من فرج معتوق يقول وما فقد الماضون
مثل محمد
ولا مثله حتى القيامه يفقد
والبيت لي حسان ابن ثابت نوال تقول وما
حملت من ناقه فوق رحلها ابر واوفى ذمه من
محمد
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ومشاركه من مريم تقول على كل شيء ما خلا
الله باطل وكل نعيم لا محاله زائل والبيت
كما تعرفون لنبيد بن ربيعه العامري
فاطمه تقول فمالي او مالي ومال الناس
مالوا على ان كسرت البيت يا فاطمه المفروض
تقولين مالي وللناس ان ماله وان عدلوا
ديني لنفسه ودين الناس للناس بهذه الطريقه
يتزن ولك البيت يا فاطمه عمر ميمون يقول
كل ابن انثى وان طالت سلامته يوما على اله
حدباء محمول
ونصرمان هذا على وزن شعر المال يقول لولا
المشقه ساده الناس كلهم الجود يفقر
والاقدام قتالوا
عبد الرحمن
يقول والنفس راغبه اذا رغبتها واذا ترد
الى قليل تقنع
هذه اذا مشاركاتكم اما انا فلو سمحتم ليبي
المشاركه فانه يحضرني بيت المتنبي الذي
يقول واسرع واسرع مفعولا فعلت تغيرا تكلف
شيئا في طباعك ضده
اشكركم هذه المشاركات واذكركم بان تضعوا
واسم تاملات الجزيره عند نهايه كل مشاركه
[موسيقى]
اروت ابن الورد العبسي من شعراء الجاهليه
وفرسانها هذا رجل لم يلتحف مجد القبيله اذ
كان من الصعاليك المعدودين
الاجواد الصعالي كما تعرفون مجموعه من
الفرسان من قبائل مختلفه من العرب خرجوا
على سلطه القبيله ورفضوا قوانينها
واعرابها واختاروا العراء سكننا والغزوه
الصلبه منهجا
للحياه شعراء الصعاليك طبعا الشمس
بنسلكه
وصاحبنا عروه ابن الورد في لسان العرب هو
الفقير الذي لا مال له
ولد عروه ابن الورد ابن زيد بن عمر ابني
عبس في زمن الجاهليه لوالد ثري وام من
قبيله قضاعه وعاش في كان في والد ميز اخاه
الاكبر وحين سئل عن هذا الامر قال اترون
هذا الاصغر لئن بقي مع ما ارى من شده نفسه
ليصيرن الاكبر عيال عليه
ربما كان هذان العاملان ان صح في روايه
الاغاني هما ما دفع عروه الى الخروج على
تقاليد القبيله وهميه سلطتها والانتقال
الى حياه الفيافي والصحراء بحثا عن مجد من
نوع خاص
قال معاويه بن ابي سفيان لو كان لعروه ابن
الورد ولد لا احببت ان اتزوج اليهم وقال
الحطيئه في جوابه على سؤال عمر بن الخطاب
كيف كانت حروبكم قال كنا نتم في الحرب
بشعره وقال عبد الملك بن مروان
من قال ان حاتما
اسمحوا الناس فقد ظلم عروه ابن الورد فما
الذي ميز هذا الفارس الشاعر لقد كان
يستهدف الاغنياء ليوزع على الفقراء وقد
لقب بعروه الصعاليك لقيادته اياهم
واعتدائه بهم وقيامه بامرهم اذا ما اخفقوا
في غزواتهم يقول
لحا الله الصالح كان اذا جن ليله
كل مجزري يعد الغنى من نفسه كل ليله اصاب
قراها من صديق ميسري ينام عشاءا ثم يصبحون
عيسى يحث الحصى عن جنبه المتعفري يعين
نساء الحي ما يستعينه ويمسي طليح كلب
المحسري
ينقل لنا كتاب الاغاني من اخباره كان عروه
ابن الورد اذا اصابت الناس سنه جديده
تركوا في دارهم المريض والكبير والضعيف
فكان عروه يجمع اشباه هؤلاء من دون الناس
من عشيرته في زمن الشده ثم يحفر لهم
الاسرار
ويكنيف عليهم الكنف ويكسبهم ومن قويه منهم
اما مريض يبرا من مرضه او ضعيف توب اليه
قوته خرج به معه
فغاره وجعل لاصحابه الباقين في ذلك نصيبه
يقول في ذلك وقد ضاقت حاله
لعل ارتيادي في البلاد وبغيتي
وشديم المطيه بالرحل سيدفعني يوما الى رب
هجمه يدافع عنها بالعقوق وبالبخل
لهذه السمات في شخصيته اطلق عليه القاب
كثيره منها ابو الفقراء وابو المساكين فقد
كان معروفا انه لم يغر على كريم يبذل ماله
للناس بل كان يختار من عرف بالخل ومن لا
يمدون للمحتاج في قبائلهم يد العون وكان
لا يؤثر نفسه بشيء على من يرعاهم من
صعاليكه فلهم مثل حظه سواء وكان هذا سواء
شاركوه في الغارات التي يشنها او قعد بهم
المرض او الضعف
[موسيقى]
اذا المرء لم يطلب معاشا لنفسه شكل الفقر
او لام الصديق فاكثر
فصار على الاذنين كلا واوشكت صلات ذوي
القربى له ان تذكر
وما طالب الحاجات من كل وجهه من الناس الا
من اجد وشمر فسر في بلاد الله والتمس
الغنى داعش كذا يسار او تموت فتعذره
ايضا ان امرئ عافي شركه وانت امرئ عافي
انائك واحد
اتهزا مني انسى منك وانت راضي شحوب الحق
والحق جاهدوا اقسم جسمي في جسوم كثيره
واحسن قرح الماء والماء البارد
عرف عنه اذا كما قلنا الكرم والتعفف وحسن
معامله النساء ودفعه عنهن تقول فيهم امراه
عاشت معه لفتره ولدت له ابناء ثم عادت الى
اهلها
يا عروه اما والله اني اقول فيك وان
فارقتك الحق والله ما اعلم امراه من العرب
لقد سترها على بعل خيرا منك واغض طرفا
واقل فحشاء واجود يدا واحمال حقيقه فرجع
راشدا الى ولدك واحسن اليهم
يقال انه عروه توفي في غاره من غاراته لكن
صوته بقي بقاء افكاره النبيله وبقاء وقوفه
مع الضعيف واحتقاله للمخلاء
دعيني للغناء اسعاف اني رايت الناس شرهم
الفقير
وابعدهم واهونهم عليهم وان امثاله حسب
وخير
ويقصيه النبي وتزدريه
حليلته وينهره الصغير
ويلفى ذي الغنى وله جلال يكاد فؤاد صاحبه
يطير
قليل ذنبه وذنب جنب ولكن للغنى رب الغفور
[موسيقى]
هل غادر الشعراء من متربع
امهى الاذى بالعين ظرف الادمعي يا دار عبس
بلغي اطلالنا ان الرسوم تبدلت في المرجع
زالت ديار الراحلين ولم تزل تعلوا الحناجر
صادقات المطلعين السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]